[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ankylosaurs were one of the most remarkable of dinosaurs.
Perhaps, the most heavily armored of any animal
that world has ever seen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They're so odd.
I think they're one of the most bizarre animals.
When you look at the proportions of their bodies,
there are questions around how they even
walked, how they moved.
They had spikes extending from their shoulder
regions, a bony covering of armor all over their heads.
Some of them even had bony eyelids.
One feature more than all the others
separates them from any animal alive today--
their extraordinary tail.
So what was it for?
Some ankylosaurs have very peculiar tails,
where they take the armor on other parts of the body
and elaborate it into what we call a tail club.
These are two huge lumps of armor
that are fused to the very last few vertebrae within the tail
and form this structure a little bit like a hammer.
When they were first discovered, they
were interpreted as a weapon of some kind.
This one belonged to a kind of ankylosaur,
known as anodontosaur.
But what makes us think that this was ever
wielded like a club?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Comparing ankylosaurs with animals alive today
suggests that it was.
On numerous occasions within the history of life,
animals have evolved specialized structures
that only function in combat.
These are often quite large and unusual structures,
like the horns of rhinos, the antlers of deer,
the horns of antelope.
Powerful muscles and reinforced bone
allow them to use these structures as weapons.
Fossils show ankylosaur tails had similar adaptations.
There's evidence on the pelvis for muscles that extended down
the tail and that would have attached
to the handle of this tail club.
It's very stiff.
It's stiffened by lots of bony rods
that run along the length of the tail that
would have had a lot of force behind it
when it was swung from side to side.
Some paleontologists have calculated
that it could be swung with enough force
to devastate a car.
It would have made a formidable weapon to defend itself
against enemies.
But now, scientists are asking a new question.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In theory, ankylosaur tails would
have been able to break the legs of predators.
But it's possible that they were also using their tail clubs
for fighting a rival for a mate, or to be
the leader of the pack.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In fact, the most recent study from 2022
reveals injuries among ankylosaurs
that proved they used their clubs for fighting each other.
We are one step closer to fully understanding
this bizarre-looking dinosaur.
[MUSIC PLAYING]